take a look at these meetings of world
leaders from the past ten years and
you'll likely notice one figure this is
German Chancellor Angela Merkel one of
the most influential leaders of Europe
her leadership spans 13 years and four
terms distortion focus Whitman
so Vanya what's happened in that span
she became one of the most powerful
women in the world but recently she
stepped down as leader of her party and
she won't be running for re-election
he's a Fiat on sight it's mental it's
though it's Buddhist Council on
disability Dutch won by 2021
not only will Germany lose one of its
longest-serving leaders so will Europe
Merkel has dominated European politics
for decades so how did Angela Merkel
become so powerful and what is her exit
mean for Europe
[Music]
the Berlin Wall divided Germany's
capital in half for almost three decades
this side was part of the prosperous and
democratic West Germany and on the other
side was an impoverished and communist
East Germany a satellite state of the
Soviet Union when the Wall fell in 1989
the East unified with the West and
Germany quickly became one of the
largest and most populous countries in
Europe this is when Angela Merkel
entered politics she was elected to be a
member of the new Parliament in 1990 but
rapidly rose through the ranks by 94 she
was Minister of the Environment and by
2000 she was head of her political party
the CDU while Merkel became more
important in Germany reunited Germany
became more important in Europe it
became a leader in the European Union
there were open borders between EU
member countries to let people and trade
pass through freely and Germany led the
effort to create the eurozone where 11e
you countries adopted the euro as a
common currency in 1999 these policies
made EU countries more dependent on each
other and in the early 2000s the EU
increasingly looked to Germany one of
its most powerful economies to be its
leader starting in 2005 that leadership
came from Angela Merkel
merkel was elected germany's chancellor
and demonstrated a talent for building
consensus she engineered a grand
coalition between germany's biggest
political parties from the right and the
left with this alliance behind her
merkel solved two of germany's biggest
economic problems she cut government
spending and reduced unemployment her
ability to stabilize Germany's economy
became particularly important when the
EU faced a crisis that was it is a
high-stakes game where the players are
world leaders and the wager is the
world's economy the global economic
recession in 2008 hit Greece especially
hard the country inched towards
bankruptcy and its economic decline
brought down the value of the euro which
hurt everyone in the eurozone but
Merkel's Germany was weathering the
recession better than anyone in Europe
so it fell on Merkel to rescue Greece
with her economic strategy she demanded
Greece pass huge spending cuts in
exchange for loans from the EU and the
International Monetary Fund these were
deeply unpopular across Europe cutting
Greece's pensions and services were
harsh tactics but Merkel's priority was
to retain the integrity of the eurozone
and Greece's debt threatened that Union
sunshine that stuff pasión Merkel
eventually got the 16 eurozone countries
to support her plan and kept the
eurozone together cementing her role as
the unparalleled but controversial
leader of Europe within Germany Merkel's
popularity continued to grow Germans
called her mu T meaning mother for
taking care of their economy
she even earned her own emoji
representing her trademark hand gesture
and in 2013 she won her third term as
Chancellor but this term would turn out
to be very different than the others the
number of migrants coming into Europe
this year alone is now at more than
500,000 almost 900 people drowned as
they attempted the crossing from Libya
to the EU some countries are greeting
them with the open arms others are
setting up fences with barbed wire on
top in 2015 more than 1 million refugees
fled conflicts in northern Africa and
the Middle East and migrated to Europe
Merkel called on EU leaders to help take
in refugees
but several European nations pushed back
as nationalist politicians in these
countries stoked anti-immigrant fears
this time Merkel could not build a
consensus migrants piled up in Europe
southern countries causing a
humanitarian crisis while undermining
the Solidarity of the EU so Merkel acted
alone in situation thus via Alameda and
Otsu Zaman hang and moons are named
after phone by Louisville friend Vanessa
it was likely his Kishida Otis VN will
respond from soil and - nincada from
beneath Cannes Festival in 2015 Germany
granted asylum to over 140,000 migrants
more than any other European country at
first things went well 33 percent of
Germans said the country could take on
additional asylum seekers many even met
incoming trains carrying migrants with
support and supplies but on New Year's
Eve in 2015 the situation changed a day
after the allegations of mass sexual
assault were made public cologne
continues to search for the perpetrators
and for answers the attackers described
as young men of Arab or North African
appearance a rash of sexual assaults and
thefts changed public opinion
after the attacks in Cologne only 18% of
Germans felt the country could take in
more acai leaves and German public
opinion reversed on Merkel - a far-right
party called the alternative for Germany
or AFD seized on the anti-immigrant
sentiment among voters 1.5 million
voters who had previously backed
Merkel's grand coalition in 2013
switched their support and voted for the
AFD in 2017 having lost support for her
coalition government in 2018 Merkel
decided to step down as leader of her
party though she'll remain Germany's
Chancellor until her term ends in 2021
Merkel's party recently elected on a
gret cramped Karen Bower as its next
leader
she's a moderate Merkel Ally who could
very well become Germany's next
Chancellor
but for the rest of Europe Merkel's
absence could be more unsettling since
the eurozone and migrant crises Europe
has seen nationalist political parties
gain popularity in recent elections
threatening the unity of the EU and
Merkel has gone from being a champion of
a united Europe to its last remaining
strong defender with Merkel stepping
away these nationalist leaders could
gain influence over the future of the
European Union and that's something
Merkel is very aware of that I lighted
mr. Matsui gonk the host for the moons
website we are Indian or my son then it
says a Manhattan when Miss Andaman
immigrants and in Vick Sue's Amman
so in this video we touch briefly on the
idea of a European identity and if
that's something you're interested in
learning more about you should check out
this really great doc called the story
of Europe on curiosity stream it walks
you through the different chapters of
European history
curiosity stream is a subscription
service that offers over 2,000
documentary and nonfiction titles from
some of the world's best filmmakers you
can get unlimited access to curiosity
streams starting at $2.99 a month and
because you're a Vox fan that the first
30 days are free if you sign up at
curiosity stream com forward slash box
and use promo code box